[Music]
when somebody lets you down you can't
spend a second on it if you're gonna
give and you're gonna expect nothing in
return I've got big news for you A lot
of people are going to give you nothing
in return I help somebody get into a
deal it was closed I reopened the deal
got them in they made millions of
dollars on a fifty thousand dollar
investment couple years later my second
book came out I said yo bro can you buy
a bunch I'm just trying to sell as many
as possible dude had nothing for me
other people I met one time one time and
they were buying hundreds karma is
practical do the right thing it's gonna
work out if you need somebody else to do
something for you to get yours you're
already broken